hey reject nation damn it Rachel
Harry zag nation that's Greg Alva here
with adorkable Rachel who I emotionally
abused when the camera's not rolling we
are gonna watch today an honest trailer
for The Incredible Hulk you've seen this
movie right yes I've seen this movie I'm
excited for it too might be my least
favorite Marvel movie damn it all right
let's do this
I really like the finale of this movie
and I like the action scenes in the
movie but I think everything in between
is kind of dull it's not the best I
think my least favorite is probably
Thor's darkness oh you just come with a
popular opinion no no I'm serious I was
never a huge Thor fan until Ragnarok
came out this one though is like it's
okay I always keep fantasizing though
and I remember in the past the last time
I watched I was like I want to see this
movie but with Mark Ruffalo in it I
don't know ever so used to Mark Ruffalo
now is the defining whole screen junkies
honest truth let's do it
my friend John Bailey John Bailey and
speaking of John Bailey actually we did
an infinity war movie rue that has an
opening sketch on there and the shirt
I'm wearing in it I borrowed from John
Bailey there you go
[Laughter]
oh yeah from Marvel Studios and
Universal fans the second movie in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that we're
doing it on its trailer for because
infinity Wars coming out we've already
done all the other MCU movies and black
panther isn't on meet Bruce Banner no
not the one people like I know who's
that you never played the whole Diddy
yeah no you know the one I'm talking
about the death of smoochy guy very wary
as the first Marvel actor to show off
how many crunches he did for the part
yeah he's bringing his incredible range
to a role that hasn't act like he's on
xanax I know a few techniques could help
you manage that
while off-camera he's bringing his
incredible ego that was his name because
that's a lot Terrence Howard it'd join
Bruce for a story where he runs away
from the military runs away from the
military and runs away from the military
yes actually though but sometimes one is
little bit bit thing he hits 200 he'll
turn into the Hulk an unstoppable rage
monster that's actually a huge danger to
the entire planet the economy of Brazil
the economy of satellite that far
yeesh I'm glad he grew up tonight planet
hall there wouldn't mean Earth left for
that us to punch before gwyneth paltrow
chat the four-year hiatus and before
natalie portman took an indefinite
absence dumped us mutual dolphin Liv
Tyler dropped off the face of the MCU
without so much as an easter egg stand
and smile as the actress spends most of
the movie standing doesn't get anything
or even anyone to do I can't man matchup
against a villain that could equal his
powers well too bad because he's
fighting the skinny British guy from
Reservoir Dogs he's a decorated veteran
with zero personal connection to Bruce
Banner and zero threat to the Hall but
when he shoots himself full of tainted
Captain America juice he'll turn into
one of the most forgettable monsters in
the MCU the mixture to be side by side
while this whole universe thing on
autopilot where our nerd boners would
only get little taste of fanservice a
sequel was only widely employed instead
of blatantly setting up five more movies
they put its post-credit scene before
the credits I told you we were putting a
team together and didn't make a billion
dollars oh that's like green lantern
money oh I know what it's like
you know about expectations haha wrap it
for this odd sequel Rico reboot origin
movie that's better than we give it
credit for because whatever you think
about the film itself
it gave us Mark Ruffalo and pave the way
for Ed Norton to join Wes Anderson's
fancy boy Cinematic Universe oh man I
cannot wait for the Royal Tenenbaums to
fight Steve Zissou in Budapest hotel
infinity floor okay Green Goblin nobody
put yourself lash Thompson in this
quirky hotel gets away with it still I
am Jack's departure due to creative
differences
Iggy Pop my Iggy Pop got an Iron Man
suit the DS voicing and teenage mutant
ninja heroin addict
the disposable yeah it's probably not
the first time a white guy got so
hammered in Brazil he woke up half naked
in Guatemala that's more than I ever
wanted to know about you John Bailey oh
hell no Karen keep your blind ass potato
salad to yourself I control all the bats
all the bats clouds or just go she $50
fine and time served oh okay no that was
the wife oh it was so random though the
bring in the West Anderson event I mean
I get it but it was still just like
really love this who's ever ignored has
become one of his like go-to actors I
thought they were gonna be a little more
harsh on this on this movie actually I
felt like they were kind of a little
light I know I'm actually insulting you
and looking back at the effects too like
they're a little dated I'm surprised
they didn't like they're a little dated
I remember when they had the whole come
in I thought it was clever about it was
they dark in the cinematography and they
darkened the Hulk because that way
looked a little bit more real at the
time it looked like incredibly good like
that whole fight scene with him and
abomination I thought looked amazing the
first time I saw the only reason every
watching theaters was just to watch that
finale one last time Edward Norton in
this movie I think is a very boring
Bruce Banner yeah I know it just said
too bad because ed Noir
is usually such as a compelling act this
one is just like man it seemed like he
didn't want to be in the movie I did not
know that was his action that was his
fake name Edward Harris I did not know
about that little piece of trivia
that's so weird that's a really
interesting fact writers I heard he did
some like annoying rewrites that pissed
off everyone yeah maybe I didn't know
that they had put him in as like a
screenwriter though yeah I Liv Tyler
never coming back I think is a great
point out of the she's never even
mentioned and that's his Pepper Potts I
know I love Liv Tyler - I would love to
see her in the MCU more I would love to
see her in a it's funny that only like
William Hurt who plays general Ross is
the only one who's come back and I feel
like Liv Tyler's character is such an
important character to Bruce Banner the
last time we saw Bruce have any type of
romantic interest is with natasha
romanoff
unless you yeah exactly yeah Black Widow
just because weird I'm thinking of her
they think they could have come up with
a better starring role for Liv Tyler's
character so thought it was funny so
that a good job I mean I could have put
this together
yeah like kudos to them for that but I
think they could have a little bit more
fun yeah there could've been a little
bit of harsher on it if a woman really
loves a man and if he had this whole
gamma ray problem she would just let him
do it as the Hulk no comment
I think adorable Rachel agrees and I
think if you have a Hulk problem find
her on tinder she will agree to date so
I came here right you want me to plug
you on tinder you do I remember about
this post-credit scene or what should
have been a post-credits scene and not
the ending with Iron Man and and Ross
they showed that in the trailers oh they
did they were so desperate to get people
to see better if we just knew afterwards
because then it would have been a nice
it would have been a nice surprise but
they had to get the scene before the
credits and they also had to show it in
the trailer which is kind of like
negates the whole effect of the scene
because that's a big mislead I saw this
at an advance screening to promote the
movie not like a press screening okay
yeah where they're like we got to get
audiences to see it so people can hype
this up there was no trailer out that
showed Iron Man in it and I think when
they did the trailers for this they were
like no one's gonna care about it I
think a lot of people walked into this
movie feeling disappointed that Iron Man
even in the movie because I'd be a
little mad too if I saw Tony Stark and
there was no Iron Man in there at all
when I first saw this movie I didn't
think it had any connection to emcee
whatsoever then I'm all of a sudden 20
Stark was at the end I was like yeah in
the trailer itself and I later they
point out the box-office report on this
because this is like technically the
only Marvel film in the MCU that has not
performed well right in terms of like
it's not even the worst one either at
least it's not the least bad I think
it's the least engaging one I don't know
I don't hate Thor the dark world like
everyone else does I know everyone
doesn't like Thor the dark world that's
out might be one of the few who enjoys
that movie I'm just not able to get into
it like the other ones that's all I've
always thought doomsday and bbs look
like abomination I didn't think about
that until I saw that now they put this
side by side and I'm like wow they look
almost exactly alike yep doomsday is
just a little darker except doomsday
actually looks a little cooler in
comparison to abomination it looks a
little cooler than say he looks a lot
better yeah anyway screen junkies thanks
for putting this together had a good
time John Bailey great voiceover as
always and if you guys want to know a
thing or two about John Bailey he will
break into that voice whether or not
he's recording in a voice booth matter
of fact John Bailey breaks into a lot of
voices when you're just hanging out with
a guy you watch amongst artists he does
impressions of a lot of people on his
reactions by the way I'm just hanging
out with him he'll do a plenty of
impressions without you even being
prepared for it he's a talented man
anyway guys you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell more importantly don't subscribe to
us subscribe to adorable Rachel
reactions reviews over on her channel as
well trust me well worth it or else I
wouldn't have invited her on